gta modders are here to finish the fight
in court we're also talking about how
halo battlefield and death loop are
fixing some things
so after being slapped with the lawsuit
from publishing giant take two
interactive a group of modders have
decided to fight back in court the
modders were originally sued for their
project re3 which reverse engineered the
source code for gta 3 and vice city
allowing the games to run on nintendo
switch and playstation vita and what's
interesting to me is that this lawsuit
was filed just two months before we got
the official release of those two games
on nintendo switch versions that are not
running that well but if you want to
know more about whether you should play
the gta definitive edition on switch
then might i recommend dave klein's
video
i'll put the thumbnail right here this
is what you're looking for go click it
after this now back to the lawsuit the
modding group however is denying
accusations of copyright infringement
from take two stating that they quote
respectfully request that the court
enter judgment in their favor and
against plaintiff denying plaintiff all
relief sought herein nailed it i could
have been a lawyer meanwhile take two
has claimed that the modding group's
reverse engineering and distribution of
re-3 has caused and is continuing to
cause irreparable harm to the company
through the lawsuit take two is seeking
damages and injunction and other
equitable relief against defendants and
those working in concert with them
however the modding group's denial
hinges on an argument that re3 doesn't
actually contain any rockstar created
assets instead the mod simply contains
functional reverse engineered versions
of gta 3 and vice city's machine code
which the group argues falls under fair
use another recommendation is the best
glitches video that we also put up we
got a lot of gta for you
moving on to halo developer 343
industries is making major changes to
the game's battle pass progression
system in wake of a wave of negative
feedback the changes that were outlined
on wednesday evening are now live in the
game and 343 says this is only an
initial step here's a rundown of the
changes halo infinite players can now
earn xp by completing match made games
the play 1 game daily challenge is worth
50 xp each the challenge deck is also
being updated to better serve players of
all skill sets additionally xp boost
will now last for 1 hour rather than 30
minutes as a result of these changes all
progress on active daily and weekly
challenges will need to be reset however
all players who sign in between november
23rd and 30th will receive this week's
ultimate reward
and keeping with the shooter news let's
talk about battlefield 2042 because the
rubber banding issue we spoke about
yesterday should be fixed soon other
changes include renaming of the
problematic boris skin a fix for allied
player names not displaying correctly
and more the update also re-enables the
proc sensor gadget which was temporarily
removed from the game in order to
improve server performance this update
is just the first of three updates
planned for the game in the next 30 days
but in other update related news death
loops second major patch is out now on
ps5 there are new field of view and
motion blur options while ui buttons and
text in menus are now larger to help
address accessibility concerns the
november 18th patch also makes changes
to npc behavior in a number of ways npcs
will now react more appropriately to
bullets that nearly miss them while they
will also react more realistically when
one of their npc friends is assassinated
nearby npcs are also getting smarter and
can now hear better and react faster to
your movements as well as determine the
direction of an incoming grenade and
react accordingly the new death loop
patch also fixes a series of bugs
including visual glitches and a problem
that could make closed doors look as if
they were open you can see the full
patch notes over on gamespot.com
okay homework time go watch those videos
i mentioned and then afterwards go
update the games that i was talking
about in this video
unless you have auto update on then it
kind of already took care of itself
[Music]
you